aquí
[Música]
cuando conocemos a alguien por primera
vez una de las cosas que una pregunta es
cuál es tu trabajo en mi caso cuando
respondo que soy científica y que
trabajó para la nasa generalmente pasan
tres cosas la primera reacción siempre
es de incredulidad me dice me está
jodiendo mentira supongo que porque les
da la sensación la nasa suena como algo
muy lejano algo que vemos en las
películas y les parece raro que alguien
como yo como ustedes pueda trabajar ahí
pero una vez que pase esa sorpresa
inicial la segunda reacción siempre es
de curiosidad y ahí es cuando me matan
la preguntas sobre mi trabajo
y lo que pasa después generalmente es un
poquito de desilusión al principio
cuando les explicó que en esta búsqueda
de vida extraterrestre de nuestro
sistema solar no esperamos a encontrarte
ni expoquimia alf ni cualquiera sea tu
alias favorito
cuando hablamos de vida extraterrestre
nos referimos a una vida mucho más
primitiva para lo que sería
microorganismos una vida que no está tan
evolucionada como la vida en la tierra
en el momento de decidir a dónde buscar
y cómo empezar esta búsqueda
lo que hacemos es usamos el único
ejemplo que tenemos de vida que es la
vida en la tierra como punto de partida
y esa toda la información que tenemos
sobre la vida en la tierra guía nuestra
búsqueda
por ejemplo una cosa que entendemos
sobre la vida en la tierra es que
necesita agua líquida para subsistir y
posiblemente se generó en la presencia
de agua líquida entonces en el momento
de decidir cuáles son los lugares en
nuestro sistema solar que son más
relevantes para esta búsqueda lo que
hacemos es seguimos el rastro del agua
por esta razón nos interesa estudiar a
marte porque sabemos que martes en su
pasado era muy parecido a la tierra
tenía atmósfera tenía lagos y ríos en su
superficie
más tarde en su historia marte perdió su
atmósfera y debido a eso perdió el agua
en la superficie pero existe la
posibilidad de que se había vida en esos
ecosistemas que haya dejado algún rastro
y que nosotros lo podamos encontrar
pero hay otros lugares en nuestro
sistema solar que son quizás más
interesantes todavía durante muchos años
pensamos que el único lugar en el cual
existía agua líquida era la tierra pero
ahora sabemos gracias a muchas misiones
exitosas de la nasa que existen lugares
en nuestro sistema solar que tienen agua
líquida en la actualidad esto es lo que
llamamos mundos oceánicos son varias
lunas una de ellas que nos interesa
mucho se llama europa es una luna de
júpiter esta luna tiene un océano que
tiene el doble del volumen de los
océanos en la tierra ese océano está en
contacto con un centro rocoso de la luna
y está cubierto por una capa de hielo
que creemos puede tener entre 10 a 100
kilómetros de espesor
también sabemos por las imágenes que
tenemos que hay grietas en la superficie
lo cual nos indica que hay un
intercambio entre el agua del océano y
la superficie
si bien nos encantaría llegar al océano
para ver qué hay ahí no tenemos todavía
la tecnología necesaria pero debido a
que existe ese intercambio entre el
centro y la superficie podemos aterrizar
en la superficie y analizar esas
muestras de la superficie y tratar de
buscar pistas sobre si existe vida o no
el descubrimiento de vida en otro
planeta sería probablemente uno de los
más importantes de nuestra la historia
de la humanidad
como tal necesitamos evidencias que sean
muy concretas en esta búsqueda los
científicos tenemos que estar
completamente convencidos de lo que
encontramos en el momento de anunciar
este hallazgo entonces cómo emprendemos
esta búsqueda de nuevo volvemos al único
ejemplo que tenemos que es la vida en la
tierra
otra cosa es fundamental que sabemos es
que dentro de todas las opciones de
moléculas orgánicas que tiene a su
disposición la vida elige la vida elige
un pequeño set y es ese es el que usa
para todas sus funciones entonces lo que
hacemos es tratar de hacer análisis
químicos buscando estas distribuciones
de moléculas que nos puedan indicar si
una muestra proviene de tiene origen
biológico o no
por ejemplo si tuviéramos dos caras dos
bolsas de caramelos y una está producida
por la vida y la otra no lo que veríamos
sería que la bolsa que no está producida
por la vida tiene caramelos de todos
colores distribuidos más o menos
uniformemente
en cambio la bolsa de caramelos
producida por la biología vale decir los
caramelos que más le guste esa bolsa va
a tener una selección de colores verde
amarillo naranja por ejemplo entonces si
le sacamos una foto a estas dos bolsas
es claro que son diferentes y es claro
que fueron producidas de manera
diferente lo que nosotros intentamos
hacer es observar sacar esa foto y ver
esos colores pero a través de análisis
químicos
en cierta forma nuestro trabajo se
parece al de un perito forense si lo
pensamos cuando se cometió un crimen el
perito forense llega a la escena del
crimen recolecta evidencias las trae a
su laboratorio y hace análisis para
convencer a un juez a un jurado de
enviar a la persona que cometió el
crimen a prisión
la ventaja que tiene el perito forense
es que puede tiene todo el tiempo del
mundo para sus análisis puede usar sus
dos manos para recolectar las muestras 3
su laboratorio con suerte tiene muchos
instrumentos a su disposición nosotros
no tenemos esa suerte mi escena del
crimen se encuentra a 300 millones de
kilómetros de la tierra es océanos
genera un problema
entonces como hacemos lo que tenemos que
hacer es elegir qué instrumento queremos
llevar con nosotros a ese planeta para
estudiar lo miniaturizados lo ponemos en
un robot y enviamos ese robot para que
recolecte las muestras y haga el
análisis por nosotros
ese robot tiene no solo que funcionar
correctamente sino que tiene que
sobrevivir el lanzamiento el viaje hacia
europa por ejemplo que puede tardar
entre 3 a 6 años tiene que sobrevivir el
aterrizaje en un terreno completamente
desconocido en el que no hayamos
aterrizado nunca antes y una vez que
llega a la superficie lo dejamos ahí
solito a la interperie y tiene que
recolectar las muestras analizarlas con
cada instrumento que enviamos todo
automatizado y mandando los datos de
vuelta para que los científicos los
podamos analizar
no solamente tiene que hacer todo esto
de manera independiente sino que además
lo hacen en unas condiciones que son
extremadamente hostiles sacamos a
nuestro robot de este ambiente ideal que
tenemos en la tierra de temperatura y
presión y atmósfera y lo enviamos a la
superficie de europa donde la
temperatura en la superficie puede
llegar a ser de menos 200 grados
centígrados o sea un poquito frío
no sólo eso sino que debido a que europa
no tiene atmósfera y está tan cerca de
júpiter está bombardeada la superficie
por radiación entonces tenemos que
diseñar nuestro robot para que pueda
resistir esa radiación
otra cosa importante es que si algo sale
mal por ejemplo no podemos llamar el
técnico y manda lo que va a arreglar
nuestro robot entonces parte de nuestro
trabajo consiste en tratar de prever
todas las cosas que pueden salir mal y
tratar de tener un plan para mitigarlas
y tratar de que todo salga bien con
suerte
obviamente este tipo de misiones y el
desarrollo de este tipo de instrumentos
no es el trabajo de una sola persona ni
de cinco ni de diez son cientos de
personas que están involucradas
se trabaja con gente de disciplinas muy
variadas gente por ejemplo ingenieros
electrónicos ingenieros mecánicos
físicos químicos geólogos y no solamente
se trabaja con gente de la nasa sino que
también colaboramos mucho con gente de
universidades e incluso con gente de
otros países lo que tenemos en común es
que todos estamos emocionados con estas
misiones todos tenemos mucha curiosidad
todos trabajamos muy fuerte juntos en
equipo dejando el ego de lado para que
las misiones sean exitosas y para poder
tratar de responder todas estas
preguntas básicas que tenemos sobre el
universo
una de estas preguntas que intentamos
responder es cómo se generó la vida en
la tierra y también cuál es la
posibilidad de que exista vida más
parecida a la tierra vida inteligente en
otros sistemas solares
como la vida en la tierra está tan
avanzada nos es difícil estudiar algo
que pasó tanto tiempo atrás pero al ir a
un lugar un planeta que no está tan
avanzado como la tierra es casi como
viajar en el tiempo vamos y eso nos
puede dar pistas sobre cómo se generó la
vida en la tierra
este descubrimiento el hallazgo de vida
en otro planeta no solamente va a tener
significancia científica sino que además
se va a extender a otros ámbitos de
nuestra vida va a tener implicaciones
filosóficas implicaciones psicológicas y
hasta va tocan en el tema religioso
imagínense que de un día por el otro
nuestra realidad cambie por completo de
repente ya no somos los únicos la tierra
deja de ser ese lugar especial que era
el único que tenía vida entonces la
pregunta es cómo vamos a reaccionar los
seres humanos frente a esta nueva
realidad
y el eje de nuestra existencia se basa
en este principio de que somos los
únicos entonces en el momento en que
esta realidad cambie más allá de
nuestras diferencias sociales políticas
geográficas los seres humanos como como
raza nos vamos a tener que unir y tratar
de redescubrir cuál es nuestro lugar en
el universo y quizás al entender desde
dónde venimos podemos descubrir hacia
dónde vamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah